ce week-end le parti présidentiel Renaissance
a fait sa rentrée politique
à Bordeaux
alors que plusieurs
noms circulent
pour conduire la liste de
la majorité aux prochaines élections européennes
le candidat naturel serait Stéphane Séjourné
dirigeant du parti présidentiel et président du groupe Renew
au Parlement européen
la troisième force politique
sauf que problème il hésite à continuer sa carrière européenne
et face à Jordan Bardella et Marion Maréchal
qui sont des vraies
bêtes de scène
certains au sein de la majorité estiment qu'il ne fera pas le poids
« Emmanuel Macron aimerait vraiment que Bruno Le Maire soit tête de liste »
c'est qu'a dit un proche du chef de l'état à La Tribune Dimanche
qui souhaite alors une incarnation politique forte
pour ces élections européennes
le nom du commissaire européen au marché intérieur
Thierry Breton a beaucoup circulé récemment
il a été ministre de l'Économie sous Chirac
et a dirigé plusieurs entreprises
il vient donc de la droite
ce qui serait un moyen d'affaiblir encore plus Les Républicains
et dans l'entourage du président
on vante sa solidité et
son expérience
qui seraient des atouts face aux extrêmes
pour une tête de liste davantage marquée à gauche
le nom de Pascal Canfin revient souvent
c'est un ancien écologiste qui a été ministre au début du quinquennat Hollande
aujourd'hui il est député européen
et a beaucoup travaillé sur le « green deal »
s'il était désigné
tête de liste
le but serait de prendre des voix aux écologistes et aux socialistes
au risque d'en perdre
à droite
il y en a une qui a pas caché son envie de conduire la liste
c'est Laurence Boone
l'actuelle secrétaire d'État chargée de l'Europe
qui est très peu connue
du grand public
elle a été conseillère économique de François Hollande à l'Élysée
et secrétaire générale adjointe de l’OCDE
autrement dit elle a un profil un peu trop techno
pour une campagne qui s'annonce hautement politique
Amélie de Montchalin
l'éphémère ministre de
la Transition écologique dans le gouvernement Borne
souhaiterait elle aussi conduire la liste
mais comme pour Laurence Boone
son profil ne suscite pas beaucoup d'enthousiasme
au sein de la majorité
certains plaident pour une candidature surprise
et évoquent le nom de Christiane Lambert
ancienne présidente de la FNSEA le premier syndicat agricole de France
ce qui est sûr
c'est que la décision finale sera prise par Emmanuel Macron lui-même
et ce pas avant janvier prochain
je vous tiens au courant